le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
valoriser une exploitation vivre de ces
cultures ou de son élevage c'est le rêve
de tout jeune agriculteur mais ils sont
nombreux à se confronter aux mêmes
obstacles l'accessibilité au terrain
alors qu'il existe de nombreuses terres
en flèche sur l'île pour rééquilibrer
cette situation paradoxale le
département met en place un dispositif
pour inciter les propriétaires à la
location ou à la vente et pour
accompagner l'installation des
exploitants anaïs et gaël sont deux
jeunes agriculteurs en recherche de
terrains
[Musique]
l'après-midi s'achève sur la côte est
mais dans les champs de gaël la journée
n'est pas encore terminée ce jeune
agriculteur est en pleine campagne
sucrière
gaël a commencé son activité il y a 6
ans et pour acquérir une surface
convenable pour la culture de la canne
il a dû faire avec les moyens du bord
j'ai commencé avec à peu près 8 hectares
dont une part active est en location par
mon père y bâtir le cateau par l'intérêt
qu'ils étaient reprises à faire
différent pour pouvoir s'étendre et
rentabiliser son activité
l'agriculteur a dû trouver d'autres
astuces par manque de conseillers je
suis allé sur la diversification
de produits à l'hectare est en dessous
du perroy je vais avoir l'opportunité le
fait de la production animale
blanc c'est donc à sainte-suzanne dans
son élevage que gaël fait son dernier
arrêt de la journée
une course quotidienne qui aurait pu lui
être épargné comme beaucoup de jeunes
agriculteurs gaël est confrontée à la
difficulté d'acquérir des terres
agricoles
pas par manque de terrains potentiels
mais parce que les propriétaires sont
réticents à louer ou à vendre leurs
biens aux pauvres il faut aller dans un
débat au mieux expliqué pouvait dire que
la terre c'est un outil pour
l'agriculteur on va pas le vendre on va
pas le détruire on va juste préserver le
valoriser et ensuite quand il ya
changement destination tout revient au
propriétaire
à s'entendre et la situation est encore
plus désolante pour anaïs le seul
terrain dont elle peut profiter pour le
moment c'est son jardin en centre ville
pourtant cette jeune femme a en tête un
projet précis et innovant créé un
élevage porcin en plein air ont marre et
ma belle famille on ne sera plus très
donc suite à une reconversion
professionnelle je me suis inscrite à
une session de formation un brevet
professionnel pour devenir responsable
d'exploitation agricole pour réaliser
son projet anaïs a suivi une formation
sur saint-joseph pendant dix mois elle a
fait des allers retours quotidiens
mais aujourd'hui après deux tentatives
d'installation son idée n'existe encore
que sur le papier mon premier terrain à
la plaine des palmistes il a été classé
en zone naturelle ensuite en cherchons
j'ai retrouvé un autre terrain donc avec
ce propriété à la baisse à s'est
terminée au tribunal tout simplement
parce qu'on a eu un désaccord au niveau
de la durée du fermage c'est pour
trouver une solution qui bénéficie aux
deux parties que le département met en
place de nouveaux dispositifs pour
préserver et mobiliser les terres en
friche cultivables il ya aujourd'hui 44
mille hectares de surfaces cultivables à
rayons presque 7000 hectares de terres
en friche c'est un pilier de l'économie
réunionnaise l'agriculture et nous
voulons en même temps que son idole nous
aidons l'irrigation nous aidons
également à la problématique foncière
qui est le premier point d'achoppement à
chaque fois qu'un agriculteur de
s'installer d'où l'idée qui nous est
venue c'est de dire qu'on va accompagner
le propriétaire dans la vente de ce
foncier en lui accordant une prime de
3000 euros à l'hectare plafonné à 20
mille euros et ou bien s'ils souhaitent
louer son foncier c'est 2 lui verser une
allocation de 1500 euros pour tout bail
signé avec un jeune apiculteur la
collectivité va plus loin pour
accompagner les agriculteurs dans
l'acquisition de ces terres elle se
propose de garantir l'emprunt est de
prendre en charge les frais de notaire
des mesures pour faciliter le quotidien
dans un milieu parfois difficile et pour
permettre à des jeunes motivés de
concrétiser leurs projets j'ai eu le
diplôme j'ai les compétences j'ai le
réseau de distribution j'ai l'ambition
mais il me manque vraiment le terrain
c'est le conseil départemental
muntari kull qui est née pourquoi il
était alors plus le terrain ou à vendre
ça va accélérer les choses
[Musique]
le dispositif de mobilisation des terres
en friche vise à rendre ces parcelles
accessible aux agriculteurs pour inciter
les propriétaires à vendre ou louer leur
surface le département met en place un
système de primes de l'ordre de 3000
euros par hectare pour une vente avec un
plafond à 20000 euros et 2500 euros par
hectare pour une location avec un
plafond de 10000 euros pour aider les
agriculteurs en installation à acquérir
ses terres la collectivité peut aussi
garantir leurs emprunts et prendre en
charge à 100 % les frais de notaire pour
plus de renseignements vous pouvez
consulter le site du département au
www.cglpl.fr
m